que se ha logrado hasta ahora con este
acuerdo al principio el panorama se veía
complejo porque los ataques contra los
puertos no se detenían
y logrado dos cosas lo primero es
tranquilizar a los mercados en términos
de que durante los próximos seis meses
muy posiblemente la producción total de
granos y la exportación total de grano
desde ucrania y de otros mercados
tenderá a la normalización es muy
posible de que la normalización nos
alcance sino hasta el 2023 pero hay
estimaciones que piensan de que 12,5
millones de toneladas de grano tomando
al trigo como referencia puede ser un
elemento entonces desde el punto de
vista de la oferta total es algo que
tranquiliza a los mercados otra pregunta
es lo que ocurre desde el punto de vista
del precio donde las cadenas de
suministro son más complejas por lo
tanto el precio no va a tender a
disminuir hasta algún tiempo más bueno
justamente usted lo estaba mencionando
pero se le pregunto el pacto se puede
considerar suficiente es decir se ha
podido mermar este efecto que causó la
represión de los granos en los silos
ucranianos si uno toma en consideración
la alternativa esto es el término cuasi
definitivo de la exportación del grano
de esa zona evidentemente es un acuerdo
que ha favorecido a los mercados ya y
particularmente a las naciones necesitan
el grano especialmente las naciones de
medio oriente y del norte de áfrica
evidentemente en un escenario de guerra
es imposible alcanzar acuerdos
totalmente ideales pero considerando
cuál era la alternativa de un déficit
global de grano a escala mundial es muy
posible que este acuerdo haya sido el
mejor dada las circunstancias bueno hace
algunos días cuando el secretario
general de la onu antonio guterres
visitó turquía hizo hincapié en trabajar
con la unión europea y con eeuu para que
los productos alimenticios y
fertilizantes rusos vuelvan a los
mercados que está pasando con estos
insumos en rúsia
bueno hay un problema más bien de orden
político en términos de que tanto eeuu
como la unión europea intentan aminorar
el efecto a nivel económico pero el
problema con eso es que permitir la
entrada fertilizante ruso finalmente
puede implicar el colapso de un acuerdo
al menos tácito que tienen los europeos
los norteamericanos con ucrania y que
básicamente debilitar a la federación
rusa con vistas a un acuerdo negociado
de la guerra cualquiera que sea el
acuerdo esto va a tener un impacto
central desde el punto de vista la
política entonces si hay ganancia en la
economía eso va a implicar un retroceso
en la estabilidad de la alianza con
vistas a una salida negociada que sea a
favor obviamente de un cráneo